well everything's in a peak state there
i really think that's where optimal
performance lies
there's so many interesting words here
but what's performance
and what's optimal performance we're
talking about
mental ability to what
to perceive the environment quickly to
make actions quickly
what's optimal performance yeah well
it's very subjective and it
varies depending on um task and
environment so
one way we can make it a little bit more
operational and concrete
is to say um there is a sweet spot
if you will where the level of internal
autonomic arousal
aka stress or alertness whatever you
want to call it
is ideally matched to the speed of
whatever
challenge you have to be facing in the
outside world so we all
have um perception of the outside world
as exteroception and the perception of
our internal real estate interoception
and when those two think when
interoception and exterior reception are
matched along a couple dimensions
performance tends to increase
it where it tends to be in an optimal
range
so for instance if you're i don't play
guitar but i know you play guitar so
let's say you're trying to learn
something new on the guitar
i'm not saying that being in these super
high states of activation are the best
place for you to be in order to learn
it may be that you your internal
arousal needs to be at a level where
your analysis of space and time
has to be well matched to the
information coming in
and what you're trying to do in terms of
performance in terms of playing chords
and notes and so forth
now in these cases of high threat where
things are coming in quickly
and animals and humans need to react
very quickly the higher
your state of autonomic arousal the
better
because you're slicing time more finely
just because of the way the autonomic
system works it you know the the
pupil dilation for instance and movement
of the lens essentially changes your
your optics and that's obvious but in
with the change in optics is a change in
how you bend time and slice time which
allows you to
get more frames per second read out with
the guitar learning for instance it
might actually be
that you want to be almost sleepy almost
in a
uh kind of drowsy state to be able to
and i don't play music so i can i'm
guessing here but send some of the
nuance in the chords or the ways that
you're
to be relaxed enough that your fingers
can follow an external cue so matching
the movement of your fingers to
something that's pure exteroception
and so there is no perfect autonomic
state
for performance this is why
i don't favor terms like flow because
they're not
well operationally defined enough
but i do believe that optimal or peak
performance is going to arise when
internal state is ideally matched to the
space-time
features of the external demands so
there's some slicing of time that
happens
and then you're you're able to adjust
slice time more finely or more
less fondly in order to adjust to the
stimulus
the dynamics of the stimulus
you